heavy rain is causing dangerous flooding
in parts of Northern California and
threatening the safety of thousands of
people there the Russian River is rising
there they foot an hour and could swell
to 14 feet by the end of the day
emergency officials covered the
evacuation of more than two dozen
communities along the water Meg Oliver's
in Guerneville where flooding could
reach historic levels today Meg good
morning to you good morning we're just
outside downtown Guerneville which is
completely cut off in every direction
and you can see why floodwaters have
surrounded homes like this one that
fence is eight feet tall they managed to
get their car out but decided to stay
because their house is elevated the
Russian River reached flood stage last
night as of this morning it's already 5
feet above flood level they're also
concerned about major damage to local
schools and businesses many stores here
in Guerneville spent Tuesday night
putting out sandbags thousands of people
could be affected by rising waters
authorities warned the roads in this
area will be cut off and waterlogged
hillsides increased the risk of falling
trees and mudslides in a nearby town the
floodwaters have already proved
treacherous for drivers crews made
several rescues including reaching this
woman by boat the National Guard has
been called in and homeowners are
anxiously waiting this river is still
expected to rise for another 18 hours
john meg thank you a travel ordeal is
over for 183 bedraggled Amtrak
passengers who were stranded on a train
for more than 36 hours in the snowy
Oregon mountains
Amtrak strain dropped weary passengers
off in Eugene in Portland Oregon
yesterday before making a final stop in
Seattle overnight double-decker train
crashed into a fallen tree on Sunday as
it headed from Seattle to Los Angeles it
became stuck in a remote area near Oak
Ridge Oregon the train did not lose
electricity people banded together to
pass the time and Amtrak said passengers
had access to food and water
the draggled is a word though Johnny at
one point people started singing the
babies ran out of diapers I hear it
wasn't pleasant but at least are all
safe yeah
yeah up and running you know let's
remember that